bonjour et merci d'être avec moi on
dirait que sur rt france alors
l'adoption de ce plan est ce que c'est
une victoire pour le couple franco
allemand
ou bien au contraire mais je crois que
c'est d'abord une victoire pour l'europe
qui a su à travers quatre jours de
marathon et votre sujet l'a rappelé
beaucoup d'eux de diversité de points de
vue qui a su malgré tout arriver à un
accord pour mettre en place un plan de
relance tout à fait substantiel de 500 à
750 milliards d'euros pour aider les
ensembles des états membres de l'union
européenne à surmonter cette crise très
importante qui est là la crise du coc
vide vous rappeler que les états unis
ont mis en place à un plan de 2000
milliards d'euros et donc le plan de 750
milliards d'euros qui est porté par
l'europe est une réponse je crois très
adaptée alors vous l'avez dit ça ne
s'est pas fait simplement je crois qu'il
faut un peu distingué sur cette question
deux choses la question du du fonds
économique la nécessité de mettre en
place un plan de réponse de relancer sur
ce sujet je crois que c'est vraiment une
réussite
et puis d'autre part la question de la
gouvernance de l'union européenne qui
présentent des avantages et des
inconvénients
vous l'avez dit ça a permis de démontrer
une nouvelle fois que lorsque la france
l allemagne s'accordait et bien des
projets pouvaient être portée malgré les
difficultés
évidemment cela met en évidence tout à
la fois l'intérêt que présente l'union
européenne qui est celle de confronter
les points de vue des différents états
qui composent l'union
et puis la difficulté évidemment bien
c'est que cela donne peut-être une une
prime très importante au petit état aux
égoïsmes nationaux et nous en avons eu
quelques quelques exemples dans ce long
marathon de quatre jours on en arriver à
ce résultat
alors un long marathon comme vous le
dites manifestement des portes qui ont
claqué des dirigeants agacé ce sommet
n'a pas encore mis en lumière au sens de
l'union européenne ne s'entend pas très
bien je crois qu'on a fini par
s'entendre tout de même ce qu ils les
résultats de ces justement les portes
n'ont pas définitivement claqué elles
ont claqué ici et là c'est un peu une
pièce de théâtre mais comme toute
organisation politique et puis
finalement on est arrivé malgré tout à
un résultat je crois que c'est d'abord
ça qu'il faut et conserver puis d'autre
part c'est aussi l'avantagé de l'union
européenne
que peut-être du point de vue français
on ne perçoit pas toujours nous avons
l'habitude d'un système très majoritaire
dans lequel le gouvernement vient peut
relativement simplement mettre en oeuvre
sa politique alors que dans le cas de
l'union européenne nous sommes dans un
système qui est beaucoup plus composée
de poids et de contrepoids de compromis
permanent c'est une méthode de
gouvernement d'ailleurs à laquelle un
certain nombre des pays voisins des
grandes démocraties européennes sont
habitués avec des coalitions qui
contraignent ces gouvernements en
permanence à négocier les décisions qui
vont être mises en oeuvre
je crois que c'est assez positif que
l'union européenne soit 7
ce lieu de discussion qui permet à des
points de vue assez varié de de se
rencontrer les pays de l'est qui
continuent de renforcer leur
industrialisation les pays de l'ouest de
l'europe les pays du nord et les pays du
sud avec des traditions assez différente
en matière de politique budgétaire en
matière de politique sociale
et c'est justement une des grandes
richesses de l'union européenne de
confronter ses points de vue avec
parfois quelques portes qui claquent
mais ça fait partie de la discussion
et puis finalement malgré tout d'arriver
à un accord donc sur ce plan là je crois
que c'est tout de même quelque chose de
relativement satisfaisant ce sur quoi il
faut mettre le doigt aussi bien c'est le
fait que le la banque centrale
européenne a apporté largement sa
contribution à la lutte contre la crise
à la suite la crise économique à la
suite du confinement n'est ce pas être
la crise du code vide en mettant en
place une politique de quantitative
easing comme on l'appelle
d'assouplissement quantitatif pour
permettre aux entreprises de se financer
plus facilement ce avec un plan de 1500
milliards d'euros a été portée par la
banque centrale européenne et ce jusqu'à
la fin
la de l'année prochaine mais la banque
centrale a beaucoup insisté sur le fait
qu'elle ne pouvait pas seul soutenir
l'économie européenne qu'il fallait
aussi que les états y mettent du leur et
je crois que pour la première fois
effectivement à travers cette décision
historique comme on l'a dit et bien les
états n'en ont été capables au delà de
les difficultés qui parfois peuvent les
oppose et de mettre en place un plan qui
permettra ensemble de soutenir
l'économie de ce grand marché unique qui
est le nôtre alors un débat contre
t il selon vous un moment même
historique comme vous l'avait dit et on
a beaucoup parlé des pays dits frugaux
certains ils ont même qualifié de radin
votre position là dessus je crois que
effectivement la difficulté est que peut
présenter pour l'instant la gouvernance
de l'union européenne c'est que la
commission européenne fait des
propositions comme il est normal là
était aussi relayée au sein du conseil
des ministres par le gouvernement
français le gouvernement allemand
la banque centrale européenne on l'a dit
aussi une politique très très très
favorable à la lutte contre cette crise
économique
reste que 1 des organes de décision
c'est evian le conseil des ministres on
a vu dans votre sujet cet immense table
avec 30 personnes tout autour qui
discute donc les 27 représentants des
états membres et d'autre part les
représentants de l'union européenne à
proprement parler et il faut qu'ils
arrivent à s'entendre et sur ce sujet
c'est le principe de l'unanimité qui
s'applique de sorte que chacun doit
absolument être d'accord avec le
résultat alors c'est évidemment donner
une caisse de résonance et un poids
particulier au petit état on aura
entendu le le premier ministre des pays
bas qui est ce ce gendarme est contre
l'argent facile que représenterait ce
plan pour un certain nombre d'états qui
en seront les bénéficiaires mais d'une
certaine manière l'argent facile c'est
aussi pour les pays bas
le lait les pays bas ont obtenu grâce à
cette négociation un rabais de leurs
contributions ils ont obtenu que le le
pourcentage qui est liée à la perception
de la tva communautaire par les états
membres soit passé de 10 à 25%
donc c'est aussi de l'argent facile que
c'est petit état relativement te réussit
à obtenir
donc je crois qu'il ya là effectivement
d'un bon exemple de ce que l'union
européenne et bien peut encore améliorer
sa gouvernance et que très probablement
passer au principe de majorité plutôt
qu'au principe de l'unanimité pour la
prise de ce type de décision permettrait
de défendre au mieux l'intérêt commun de
l'union européenne face à ces égoïsmes
naturel des états qui s'expriment peut
être un peu trop facilement
mais dans ces conditions david caplan
merci je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'université
franco-allemande merci d'avoir été
enterrés acte avec vous